Speaker 1: Let's go next to John from Is it
pronounced Lester?
Is that the correct pronunciation?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
No, it's the last we spoke before, actually.
I remember the
Speaker 1: question I remember I always forget
because in the U.S. there are towns in the
U.S. with the same spelling, but we call them
they're.
Speaker 5: That's fair.
I mean, I used to call things like that because
I'm from South Wales, so I don't know if you've
noticed my accent.
I do the most from most English people.
I always try to loughborough Luka Veruca when
I first came here and people laugh, which
is fair like.
But.
Speaker 1: Well, that's a whole other story,
probably.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I get really.
I wanted to talk to you about, I guess, mainly
it's the current political climate.
I don't know.
Maybe I've been naive over these last couple
of years, but I don't know you.
Maybe you're about as worried as I am about
the overall rise in right wing opinions.
I guess the prototypical fascists.
And yet how that affects our current like,
I guess, western outlook.
Speaker 1: It sounds like I'm at least as
worried as you.
I mean, we have a few different things going
on.
First of all, you have the rise of right wing
hyper or super nationalism, and we've seen
that in a number of European countries.
We're seeing it to some degree in South America.
We're seeing it in a lot of different places.
In addition to that, Trump in the U.S. pulled
a ton of people who were not previously engaged
with politics into the political space, and
they're almost exclusively horrible people.
And some of them are like remaining involved
for now.
Now, depending on what happens here in the
U.S. in November, they may become unengaged
or disheartened, and we'll have to wait and
see.
But you then combine that with the effect
of the radicalizing effect of social media's
filter bubbles and echo chambers, which serves
to reinforce these radical beliefs and all
of it together is a recipe for exactly the
disaster that you're pointing out.
Speaker 5: I guess as well, I guess it's hard
to hide right now, at least currently from
a British perspective, the influence as well
as other powers on, I guess, electoral systems.
We've already now people are starting to talk
in the UK about how much Russia had an effect
on the Brexit vote, which was invariably driven
by people's vitriol towards immigrants.
I can say that, like Leicester, was the only
part of the East Midlands that voted to remain
the rest of all the other counties voted Leave.
Leicester's proportionality wise, it's quite
of diversity.
It's quite nice to live in, but the counties,
it's like ninety nine point nine, four percent
white British Leicester, 40 percent white
British.
And then we pretty much, I think, representation
from 110 out of 140 or so nations of the world.
Speaker 1: What is the population of Leicester?
Speaker 5: All about 300 K, I reckon a million
in the Leicester, Leicestershire area.
I should know these things I do.
I've managed local projects in the NHS.
Speaker 1: That's very interesting.
And now you mentioned white British in your
area.
Is there a distinction made between white
British and like, say, French or Italian folks?
Speaker 5: I think so.
And again, it depends on probably the person
you ask.
I think if you can ask somebody, you asked
me, I'd probably talk more demographically
if you were to speak to somebody who was,
I guess, had more traditionalist values that
say they probably would actually differentiate,
then again, further and go, You know, these
people, eastern European, they're western
European.
This is a it's a quite quite tricky situation
in the UK.
A lot of people have a lot of hatred towards
people, particularly of Eastern European origin.
That's very hard for local community groups.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, you know, one of
the interesting things in the United States
is that the definition of who's considered
white has changed over time.
You know, there was a period where darker
skinned southern Italians were not considered
white.
Now, I think there are very few people that
would argue that they are not white.
But then there's questions as to whether,
you know, are are Persians?
White and white supremacists say, Well, Jews
are not white and you all these different
things.
It is very interesting how that changes, and
it sounds like at least where you are, there's
there's still at least a significant portion
that sees non-British Western Europeans as
something a little different, at least.
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
And I think it's exactly what drove a lot
of people to vote leave, is this idea an antagonistic
view if it were towards, I guess, people outside
of Britain?
Yeah.
And I can't I can't even escape it as a Welsh
person.
I've never really been one for nationalism,
but in just Welsh, nationalist, English nationalist
is the language they speak.
Speaker 1: Last thing, as a as a Welsh gentleman,
how closely do you identify sort of with like
the London mill you and culture like, do you
feel like that's kind of what you're part
of or do you really feel like you're in a
very different area?
Speaker 5: Well, I just ask you about London,
my least oversee, you know, city disaster.
Speaker 1: But I mean, I guess what I'm trying
to get to is culturally, do you feel like
you like Leicester and London are part of
the same thing or that it's really different?
Speaker 5: But I say it's similar but different.
Like a similar in the sense that it is quite
a diversity and it is quite metropolitan,
it's different in the level of, I guess, access
to public services and health care.
Like this is, you know, it's the East Midlands
city because of the lack of services, whereas
in London, I guess London's always considered
the utopia when you speak to people.
The London lifestyle and then the others in
Moscow, I think,
Speaker 1: yeah, I mean, there's some in France,
there's a lot of Paris and then everything
else and then the folks in Britain, they often
think of themselves as different as well.
That's yeah, the internal dynamics are interesting
because from far away, like in the U.S., people
just tend to have a sense of, Oh, there's
France, and then there's the U.K. and then
there's Italy.
But within these countries, there are such
dramatic differences.
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
Couldn't agree more like that.
Thanks for taking my questions.
All right,
Speaker 1: John.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you again.
All right, John from Leicester.
What
a call.
Very, very exciting there, for sure.